we have a conservative musician group
chat we all study music and we all agree
that you need a better theme song for
your show you're 180 correct it is so
true okay when you launch a company
you'll see this okay when you boot your
bootstrap yourself into existence there
are certain things that just get carried
along it's like evolutionary holdovers
and the guitar riff at the beginning is
that thing the show is starting we're
literally doing it from jeremy bourne's
pool house it was really like me in a
pool house with like a couple of guys we
were friends with and no room and it was
it's as well and we realized that we
needed some
marker for the audio editors for the uh
for the graphic to fly in the problem
was that licensing music is super
expensive we got jeremy boring's brother
to literally go in a studio and play a
guitar for 35 seconds
okay and that became that riff
then they've proposed to me several
alternatives none of them very good
right now they hear the riff and they
know that it's the show so it's actually
this terrible guitar riff has become
part of the show almost permanently